aquí tenemos dos expresiones
logarítmicas distintas una en color
amarillo y otra en color morado y lo que
quiero que hagas como siempre es pause
del vídeo y ver si puedes reescribir
estas dos expresiones logarítmicas de
una manera más sencilla y te voy a dar
una pista en caso de que todavía no
hayas empezado la pista es si eres capaz
de cambiar la base de los logaritmos o
de las expresiones logarítmicas podrás
ser capaz de simplificar esto muy bien y
te voy a dar una pista más espero que
todavía no hayas empezado cuando hablo
del cambio de base me refiero a que si
tengo cosas como como la siguiente
logaritmo logaritmo en base se me ocurre
en base a de no sé no voy a tomar el
logaritmo en base de b
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
el logaritmo en base b el logaritmo en
base b
entre el lugar y tmo en base am el
logaritmo en base a y bueno seguramente
en este momento me puedes decir oye pero
en qué base está en estos logaritmos y
es que esto es independiente de la base
que tú elijas siempre y cuando elijas la
misma base puede ser no sé logaritmo en
base 9 debe y logaritmo en base de 9 de
amd o lo que tú quieras casi siempre la
gente ocupa el logaritmo en base 10
déjame ponerlo con este color el
logaritmo en base 10 porque es la base
más usada y bueno esto se debe a que la
mayoría de las personas tienen
calculadoras que resuelven este tipo de
logaritmos o al menos tienen tablas de
logaritmos de base 10 entonces aquí
estás diciendo que el exponente al que
tengo que elevar a para que me dé d es
exactamente igual al exponente al que
tengo que llevar 10 para que me debe
entre el exponente al que tengo que
llevar 10 para que me dé
y esto es algo muy útil y que es muy
importante saber cuando quieres usar un
cambio de base en los logaritmos y esto
nos va a servir bastante para resolver
este ejercicio esta fórmula ya la
probamos en algún otro vídeo y es
momento de aplicarla
entonces regresando a esta expresión de
amarillo
puedes ver esto exactamente esto mismo
como 11 entre entre el logaritmo en base
de de 4 y bueno estas dos expresiones
son las mismas pero ahora ya podemos
utilizar el cambio de base justo aquí
podemos escribir esto de la siguiente
manera como uno entre el logaritmo
de 4 sobre el logaritmo de b y bueno es
el logaritmo en base 10 porque no
escribí la base y estamos asumiendo que
estamos en base 10 ahora sí divido un
número entre una expresión racional
puedes recordar que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que multiplicar por el
recíproco de esta expresión entonces
esto me va a quedar como 1 déjame
ponerlo aquí como 1 que multiplica al
recíproco de esto al logaritmo de b
entre el logaritmo de 4 y bueno si
multiplicamos por 1 esto es exactamente
lo mismo que el logaritmo de b entre el
logaritmo de 4 esto está muy sencillo
simplemente multiplique por 1 pero es
momento de irnos en la otra dirección
usando de nuevo esta pequeña de la que
tengo aquí porque esto va a ser esa
lo mismo que el logaritmo en base 4 y en
esta ocasión de b y ya está
llegamos a una expresión muy sencilla y
muy limpia de esta que tenía aquí uno
entre el logaritmo en base b de 4 es lo
mismo que el logaritmo en base 4 de b y
observa lo importante es que estamos
hablando para una base cualquiera
estamos tomando una b general entonces
si tomó el recíproco de una expresión
logarítmica esencialmente va a ser lo
mismo que un intercambio de bases aquí
tengo un exponente al que tengo que
elevar p para obtener 4 y aquí tengo un
exponente al que tengo que llevar 4 para
obtener b y bueno tal vez esto se ve un
poco mágico hasta que pones unos números
tangibles por aquí esencialmente con
exponentes fraccionarios y así esto
empieza a tomar más sentido por ejemplo
sabemos que 4 elevado al cubo es lo
mismo que sé
4 estás de acuerdo dicho de otra manera
el logaritmo en base 4 de 64 esto es lo
mismo que 3 de lujo y si dijera me
quiero tomar el logaritmo en base 64 de
4 cuánto es esto bueno con esta nueva
expresión que acabo de encontrar
tendremos que elevar al 64 a la potencia
un tercio para llegar a 4
entonces nota que son recíprocos
de hecho tal vez no sean tan mágicos
después de todo pero es padre ver cómo
todo esto funciona muy bien ahora
vayamos al siguiente y bueno qué te
parece si también utilizamos este cambio
de base así que que me va a quedar bueno
me va a quedar que el logaritmo
16 esto dividido entre el logaritmo el
logaritmo de c y bueno ojo de nuevo
recuerda que estoy usando logaritmo en
base 10 escribiré cada una de estas
expresiones con un logaritmo base de 10
y esto va a multiplicar a quien bueno va
a multiplicar a dejen usar este color a
logaritmo en base 10 recuerda
de ser esto dividido entre dejen de
utilizar este otro color entre el
logaritmo en base 10 de 2 una vez más
recuerda que no estoy poniendo la base
porque estamos hablando de base 10 bueno
la puedo poner aquí si te sientes un
poco más cómodo base 10 base 10 base 10
base 10 es lo mismo ahora bien observa
que por aquí tengo un logaritmo en base
10 desee multiplicando y por aquí un
logaritmo en base de 10 12
por lo tanto estos dos se pueden ir se
cancelan y simple y sencillamente me
quedaré con logaritmo en base 10 de 16
entre el logaritmo en base 10 el
logaritmo en base 10 dedos y bueno ahora
podemos irnos en dirección contraria de
nuevo porque esto va a ser igual a el
logaritmo el logaritmo en base 2 en base
2 dejen usar su respectivo color en base
2 de 16 y ojo todavía no acabamos porque
esto lo podemos resolver aquí potencia
tengo que elevar el 2 para obtener 16
bueno eso lo sabemos la potencia la que
tengo que elevar dos para que me dé 16
es
estás de acuerdo y observa que aquí
empezamos con una variable ce y en un
principio parecía que vamos a lidiar con
cosas muy abstractas pero de hecho
puedes evaluar toda esta loca expresión
simplemente al valor de 4 si tuviéramos
una competencia matemática oral y
matemático esta sería una muy buena
pregunta para poder obtener el premio
porque tú sabes pasar por todos estos
pasos estaría muy padre para obtener
finalmente el valor de 4